But can I do Budwig cottage cheese and flax seed? So this is the Budwig protocol if I'm told to
limit dairy. We've had this question about two dozen times over the years. And the answer is
if you ask the Budwig people that they'll say, oh, when you add flax seed to dairy, you change the
properties of dairy and it doesn't negatively affect you anymore. Well, that is just not a good answer
because that is just not true. You know, you can't change the protein in the dairy by adding
flax seed to it. It's still going to have the same components, still has the same peptides,
it's still going to stimulate the mTOR pathway. So that is, you know, whatever, regardless of what
they tell you on the Budwig website, it's still a dairy product. Now again, you know, if you,
if the person is like I really feel like God is leading me to do the Budwig protocol,
try this for a month, then by all means, you know, override what I told you about dairy and do it.
And if you feel like this is what God is telling you to do. But if you just are grasping that straws
because you read that somebody on Facebook used the Budwig protocol and it helped their cancer,
then I, you know, no, I mean, you're, you're not supposed to act that way. We're not supposed
to make decisions that way in anything in life. Are you supposed to make decisions that way?
So by all means, you know, be praying about your decisions and you're asking me this question,
I would say, no, you shouldn't do that. But by all means, you know, you pray about it and
do what God's telling you to do, that's more important.